bonsoir les fantasmes merci d'être avec
nous alors globalement on l'a entendue
dans ce sujet lors de ce sommet beaucoup
de voeux pieux c'est le hc d'ailleurs le
cas pardon à chaque fois mais dans les
faits pas toujours appliqué cette fois
ci doit-on y croire écoutez voudrait y
croire
on aimerait il croire mais quand
j'entends ce que vous avez publié de
l'extrait de l'intervention deux
présidents de républiques emmanuel
macron et quand je regarde les actes je
me dis qu'il va être difficile d'y
croire
parce qu'il dit qu'il faut accélérer
mais je pense qu'ils se trompent de
pédaler qu'il a les deux pieds sur le
frein
la dernière démonstration c'est la loi
climat où il ne reprend pas les
propositions sans filtre comme il s'y
est engagé de la convention citoyenne et
non seulement il ne reprend pas tout
mais ce qu'il reprend il va moins loin
que ce qui était envisagé ou suggérés
donc qu'il a faux du début à la fin et
en réalité c'est le président de la
parole président du verbe président de
la communication et malheureusement les
actes ne sont pas là ils ne sont pas là
pour quelle raison il ya des obstacles
infranchissables compliqué en france
notamment
il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord ya un
lobby extrêmement fort de gens qui n'ont
aucune envie que la transition
écologique se produise prenez le lobby
des pétroliers le lobby automobile
le lobby aussi une partie du lobby du
bâtiment n'a aucune envie ça change
leur objectif c'est profit comme
toujours et pas de vrai changement et
puis vous avez dans la classe politique
encore beaucoup d'hésitations beaucoup
d'hésitations et malheureusement à
gauche comme à droite on a bien vu
qu'avec les présidents successifs depuis
20 ans il ya eu peu d'avancé je peux
prendre un exemple la rénovation des
bâtiments ça fait dix ans qu'on en parle
et que ça n'avance quasiment pas on est
très très en retard sur les objectifs
or les solutions elles sont connues donc
quasiment tous les domaines
il faut c'est de la volonté politique
est là la volonté n'est pas là on n'est
pas du tout avec des gens qui prennent à
bras le corps notre avenir parce que
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité est quand
même c'est pas l'avenir de la planète
elle vivra très bien sans les êtres
humains elle a vécu longtemps cendres
sans nous et elle peut vivre encore
longtemps sans nous mais c'est notre
avenir de l'humanité qui est en jeu il
n'y a pas la volonté politique
c'est pour ça que nous prônons vraiment
une recomposition politique autour de
cette question de notre avenir de notre
capacité à survivre et à faire en sorte
que nos enfants petits enfants arrière
petits enfants puissent vivre dans un
climat acceptable au plan humain et pas
simplement avec quelques-uns qui a régné
ce héros mais qu'ils n'y arriveront pas
de s'en sortir au détriment de tous les
autres
alors ça c'est pour la france on est
malgré tout un petit pays
les yeux évidemment les on a les yeux
tournés vers les états unis la chine
là aussi beaucoup de voeux un changement
même à 360° des états unis réduction de
50 à 52 % d'ici 2030 pour atteindre
neutralité carbone en 2050 ce assez pour
joe biden si jean ping nuit a affirmé
vouloir atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2060 ce sont quand même des faits
importants
on peut y croire là encore oui oui c'est
important qu'il y ait ces déclarations
surtout après la période de monsieur
trump qui niait complètement qu'il
puisse y avoir un dérèglement climatique
mais il ya encore beaucoup d'obstacles
parce que on le voit bien cette
révolution climatique loi sa compagnie
et en même temps d'une réduction des
inégalités si on veut qu'elle soit
acceptée
on l'a vu avec la crise des gilet jaune
on ne fait pas d'écologie sans justice
sociale sans approfondissement de la
démocratie c'est-à-dire participation
des citoyennes et des citoyens et donc
c'est ça l'enjeu de l'écologie politique
c'est ça la république écologie et c'est
pour ça que nous nous disons que c'est
bien que monsieur byden que monsieur
poutine etc face des grandes
déclarations mais il faut passer aux
actes
il faut passer aux actes et quand on
voit les conflits par exemple sur
gaz avec la russie sa volonté de
développer des infrastructures qui sont
pas tellement écolo quand on voit
malheureusement la poursuite de grands
projets encore en chine de barrage qui
serait totalement en contradiction avec
le maintien de la biodiversité
on se dit que il faudrait sortir de ses
contradictions et pas se dire que on y
arrivera demain et en même temps au
quotidien prendre des décisions
contraires à l'ordre est atteint berg a
mis son petit grain de sel dans cette
conférence comme elle l'avait fait
d'ailleurs la dernière fois avec brio en
tout cas on l'a remarqué si j'ose dire
elle a accusé les dirigeants d'ignorer
le changement climatique
on en est là où vous êtes un peu exagéré
de la part de cette jeune fille je
trouve qu'elle a un très grand intérêt
de dire assez crûment ce que beaucoup de
gens pensent c'est à dire que je
n'aurais pas dit ignorer au sens mes
connaissances mais ignorée au sens de
une faible volonté de mettre en oeuvre
les solutions
encore une fois qu'ils sont connus au
plan de ce qu'il faut faire des moyens à
mettre en oeuvre
je vois comme ce bail d'un annonce des
sommes tout à fait que le sale mais
encore faut-il qu'elle soit réellement
utilisés et les biens d'utiliser on peut
dire qu'en france malheureusement il ya
quasiment rien dans ce domaine on est
très très très loin d'avoir une verrine
un véritable green deal comme dit
monsieur macro mais qui serait au
service de la transition écologique son
green deal c'est en fait un simple
verdissement des politiques actuelles
néolibérale mais s'il n'y a pas de
véritable volonté de changer les
objectifs et la finalité même de ce
qu'on produit
merci yves contassot d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france